hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the midnight game a video
game based on the creepypasta of the
same name a pretty famous one of you
know about and this one was actually
recommended to me by my good buddy red
wolf gamer and he says that it was
thoroughly scary so long as I know
exactly what to do and there's a lot of
rules to the midnight game if you don't
know about it we'll go over them very
quickly here I actually went in the game
and I already read all this so anyway
here we go the requisites are you need a
candle your main wooden door and at
least one drop of your own blood of
beasts paper and matches you need to
write a full name on a piece of paper
and place one drop of your own blood on
the piece of paper and loud soaked in
step 3
Oh subdue even worse than step 3 turn
off all the lights in your house go to
your door and place a paper with your
name in front of it take the candle and
light it except 322 times the are must
be 12:00 a.m. on the final knock blow
out the candle you have just allowed the
midnight man into your own house and
actually don't turn around right now
because he's literally standing right
behind you can't be joking about this do
not turn around he's literally right
behind you right now anyway then you
immediately realize your candle
seriously don't turn around and you must
look around your house in the complete
darkness to avoid the midnight man until
exactly 3:30 3:00 a.m.
Georgia cantilever guard it means the
midnight man is really really close to
you so even if your lights are
flickering right now I'd be very worried
if I were you if you're unsuccessful the
midnight man will induce a hallucination
of your greatest fear until 3:30 3:00
a.m. you must continue until 3:30 3:00
a.m. without being caught otherwise the
midnight man will just leave apparently
not stab you in the butt not leave you
away what with whatever the words those
said that but anyways do not turn on any
lights do not use a flashlight do not go
to sleep do not use another person's
blood if you can obtain that and do not
use a lighter to substitute for a candle
it won't work don't even try deaf
do not provoke the midnight man in any
way indeed he do and also you can press
tab to go to your inventory to-do list
anyway I need a match on matches I need
a knife and I need a candle I think I
have a matchbox in the kitchen I should
also search the kitchen for the rest of
the items switching the lights off one
by one will be a pain I believe there's
a master switch outside the bathroom
which I found also f2 blow out the
candle not be anymore it's f2 blow
anyway right mouse button to knock on
the door let's do this so there are some
materials in the kitchen here that we
need number one we need this knife
number two we need that candle and
number three we need the matchbox which
is right here ish No
Oh for the mad Fox go that's where it
was before
hello ah there it is okay oh and hello
nan name branded serial that no one can
tell what actually is house this semane
door is the other one main door there's
two doors over here I'm not sure which
ones the main one this se needed to be a
wooden door no oh hello well that one's
got the moon by it is that any
indication of what it woke a I just
turned into a ghost well so time for
that I got to let the midnight man do
all that for me so I'm assuming that's
probably the main one guessing anyway no
time to waste for that I also did this
cool thing cool anyway so about a boat
and then you do less you light the
candle right across my I dropped it [ __ ]
I think I needed that oh well whatever
okay then this is really fun well [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the hell I just
wasted all of my candles what how are
you kidding me I can't win now
phew phew I'm gonna get back to where I
was before [ __ ] you
alright so anyway let's try this again
without with a lot less suck
there we go and then we light it up okay
now we're doing fantastically and we can
move on with this game now what we need
to do is we need to write our name down
here and my name is Mark Edward fish
buck I need to put one drop of blood I
like these well-timed bongs not those
Neverland so now I have this and it's
balancing with demonic Glee ready to
summon the midnight man apparently had
like good there we go okay so I'm
assuming this needs to go to the main
door there's also a door that door
leaves outside but I don't know if
that's the main door it is the main ooh
okey do I need to place it on the front
as in outside of it yes no how do I know
it's right how do I know it's wrong well
crappy okay so I'm assuming that is
going then okay so right there's good
yeah it's good okay I'm gonna turn out
the lights cuz I'm a badass and I like
the darkness and I like all the monster
standing behind me in you right now
actually didn't explore the rest of the
house I don't know how long I have until
midnight hits ah that's gonna be
horrifying later here
oh god that's literally just to the
outside why would anyone put that in a
baby room anyone could just come in and
steal the baby it's terrifying okay so
is there anything in here that I would
actually need or is this all just gonna
be bunk ooh what is that lead
ooh that's dark and spooky Oh a basement
and some oddly blood-stained pieces of
tin all right well I'm never coming down
here again unless the midnight man
chases me okey-dokey
I think it's about time this buoy is
very spooky spooky scary even so now we
just need to wait until midnight and
then knock on the door I'm assuming
that's correct okay so it's pretty close
to midnight now it's a midnight no okay
so we're just gonna watch this until
midnight Oh knock on the door 22 times
and and blow out the candle okay after
blow yeah I fit to blow it here it comes
getting ready for it 22 times and then
blow blow 22
here we go one two all those counter
okay
oh yes immediately Ryan let let it be
let it be let it be let it okay
who's there who's there there a midnight
man oh that's a statue alright so don't
stay in one place and then just wander
or your own house until 333 I didn't
know if something was gonna immediately
come out and attack me oh okay I need to
relight it
what do you know shut up are you okay
that failed oh come on what the hell it
was a lobby relight it
oh what a on oh you shut up right now
you have to go I have to go to the
bathroom I have I have to go
is it me
hello
please please one
hey good that's great why wouldn't it
let me realize ah screw you
I'll be right back oh come on if this
isn't the stupidest thing I've ever seen
why did that drawer open by itself thank
you very much
there we go just a nice even pressure I
guess don't know the lights on cuz
everyone has a master switch to turn out
all their lights in their home outside
their bathroom okay yeah yeah yeah okay
Kevin OOP there we go
we're done grab it go go go go no time
there's no time
we gotta get murdered by the midnight
man on cooking one two three four five
keep them free mommy mommy mommy I'm in
a hurry midnight man murder me okay
there we go hide it hey make it look
real
yes very good however okay all right
we're in it to win it I'm ready this
time I'm not gonna be long
oh no no I got a big mouth me Oh more
mantis you get more matches oh that
makes life so much easier
so I gotta not turn on any lights well
it's time to explore the rest of the
house where's this hello is that that
was nothing I threw it on the ground cuz
I don't care who knocked this over what
did that maybe me no okay
no who's there I hear that get out of my
ear I don't much appreciate you so what
is that
I did nothing there I was all living in
the darkness I'm not joking I really did
okay okay okay
I'm gonna go down to the basement seems
like a nice place cozy safe
did I hear laughing did I just hear
laughing oh boy this is much not good or
okay so at least I'm getting oh I
thought you were dying back there for a
second
shut up who the hell do you think you
are trying to mess with me okay okay
there's my beer that's good there's no
tiny bug still to be found
that's bad shut up shut up shut up did
it start raining why and how I'm in the
basement
is that the sodomy prolifically peeing
my pants which I'm not wearing shut up
shut up shut up shut up shut up morning
the baby room okay okay Oh house and all
that bad okay okay okay you turn it up I
got ad Rebecca nice even Roger gonna be
on oh yeah get out of there whoa this
guy don't mess around all right
please don't tell me that the till 3:33
a.m. goes in real time here is that
better not I'm not playing this game for
three hours
goddamn okay much better a little better
not that much better okay so I just got
us your back man okay who's that
wait a minute oh the back door is open I
should close that good I did that that
helped that'll certainly dissuade the
dog hey what's going on all right
you gotta stop just doing things
randomly okay okay going moving woman
moving okay so I need to keep moving
around the house to be able to find more
now
hey I've seen myself again and again
well don't buy so many mirrors you
douche gun stop telling me your problems
y'all go okay good we'll sing stop
throwing themselves out me so I got to
search the house for more match boxers
but I got plenty right now oh yeah
everything seems to shut up right now
mr. midnight man sir or ma'am ma'am man
ma'am you're a man I think soon your
game do not go in the bathroom all right
Matt Fox is here where's my baby by the
way it shouldn't I be worried that I'm
in a house with a baby crib in it and
I'm probably an irresponsible dad that
just allowed this demonic present I'll
shut up thank you all right
ain't nothing it ain't nothing ain't no
thing I ain't hiding in there something
nice shouldn't be staying in one space
for too long
oh come on it was in there I saw it
ah screw you I fell back because of the
great physics in this game I got enough
I got enough shut up don't okay shut up
I should have known the whispering means
he's close oh no oh no oh no oh no come
on come on come on God come on Wow
oh come on light it off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yo not this again
this is stressful it's stressful it
won't go
sometimes I don't know my big boom bow
okay
you think you know what's up buddy Do
You Know Who I am I'm ready to rock I
turned in the ghost for a second time to
go down in tears because that's where
the most matches I found were wait a
minute wait what's this up here is there
something I need to know about should I
even be up here right now is this a good
idea is it a bad idea to be up here
hello grand piano you're the one that's
all go okay hello you fell off hi hi hi
hi hi hi okay okay hi hi hi it's okay
it's okay
getting go to that get real good all
there's so much stuff up here oh it's
like a mansion I live in a mansion with
a family I apparently don't care about
hello teddy bear go away busy I'm gonna
make it buta miles ding-dong
looks like a wacom what are those locked
why would that be locked what why would
that be locked why is that one locked
very worried about that Hey I didn't
even think that there was an upstairs
this is the master bedroom where I sleep
me sleep
Oh God an old-school chest I'm sure
there's goodies in there nope no one's
noggin
no one's answer okay all right cool
we're cool
we're good nice so we're just exploring
the rest of the house looking for our
goodies another bathroom great love
bathrooms and horror games they're the
best stop whispering in my ear no need
for that times going quick doing good
everybody kind of maybe I'm think he
knows I'm upstairs ANCA I think you
knows I'm upstairs
I'm pretty sure he knows but I'm gonna
go in the basement now so long as I keep
moving I'll be fine oh I miss my little
buddy
my little biscuit how is you're here
with me right now
my time of strife my little buddy must
biscuit I'm never doing harm you you
would protect me from the demons maybe
this alcohol protect me from the demons
surge okay very evenly very calmly RIT
collectively yes yes I'm the match
master now no shadows on the walls here
just some weird things going everywhere
giant teddy bear no baby no baby no baby
I'll be over there whispering okay drug
trip real quick that's okay I'm fine
fine if I keep telling myself I'm fine
I'm sure everything will turn out great
who would want to play this game not buy
the game I mean the video game that I'm
playing right now who would want to play
the midnight game even if there was a
chance that it could be real why would
you do that tears I'll stop talking
about your great go sometimes a lot okay
it's okay
calmly and collectively that's what it
takes sometimes you cannot even says
what's happen whose ring wronging bigger
hang on
hello that's the remote I just tried to
answer the remote so stupid I whoa okay
those guy in that room I should have
seen that I'm a collective okay calm and
collected hello hello oh did I miss it
or something i press e right there okay
sorry I missed that I'll answer you
again when I'm not being stalked by a
demon follow us and spending so much
time trying to answer the remote maybe I
would
that's how you do it that's how you do
it that's how you master this game I'm
on midnight man what do you go sorry
what was that
who was that is there someone on the
window hello hello okay my face how you
doing
you look good Oh I'll leave now what's
going on
look my games stuttering maybe the same
stop it with the shadow coming to give
me midnight man okay you're coming to
get me
alrighty then nice and even nice and
even okay ah now we're better now we're
all better now we're so much better I
keep going into the same rooms over and
over again I'm gonna go upstairs and see
if I can arm wrestle with that whoever
hello hello okay we dropped again okay
all right then I'm back hello you still
holding this okay alright then sorry
Oh someone on the other side I'll just
turn this on right there I just someone
really doesn't want me to go over there
I'm really curious about what's on the
other side there why is there blood
there oh as a blood
I am I having performance issues okay
stuttering stuttering stuttering man
yeah the graphical fidelity in this game
is just so outstanding sorry I will stop
mocking your game where am I
where am I thank you thank you okay
okay I fell out of the stairway it
turned ghost at the wrong time I'm
freakin Danny Phantom bugging lighting
on the stairs no big problem the own
mind if my framerate drops or anything
that's all cool come on
please tell me sometime I've been
playing this game Oh Simon - I can last
I can make it I can make it I can make
it okay I can make it shut up I can make
it I can make this this is insane okay
that ain't normal
that is not normal sigh another guy
who's going through this I'm not letting
that touch me no way no how no way no
way no how no way is that the ghost of
another guy who was travelling through
his house at midnight tried to win the
game
I failed possibly so far so good
you're nothing you're nothing you're
just a shadow a shadow your former self
about here oh I say to the basement you
long all right it's okay it's all right
it's all right it's all right all right
someone's still banging on the piano
upstairs it's all right it's all right
it's all right everybody don't worry
he's only standing immediately behind
you if you turn around for even one
second he's gonna claim your soul
without your worst nightmares I really
don't know where I'm supposed to go kind
of just wandering aimlessly trying to
keep moving it does not get me I don't
know where to find any more matches so
for the matches that I have don't last
then I'm kind of screwed I got ten whole
matches as long as I don't waste any of
them I should be fine
son of a [ __ ] walking like Sam whoa
what was that that was new that was
really new I'm out of here I'm out of
here which way is out I'm out I'm out e
Miley I don't care what that was I'm not
going anywhere near that I don't even
know if that was a midnight man
someone's banging a wagon someone's bang
a ringing teddy bear no baby I'm gonna
be worried when I hear in that crib and
there is a baby with that baby from
Petey just a little old fetus flailing
around and talking like a grown man what
the hell was that why did it just get
really dark for a second there why you
want to know do I even want to know how
do I keep wanting to go back in the
kitchen okay no oh no no no oh no no
let's following me oh my god oh no no
not now will you light it like that like
oh that is following me I'm out I'm out
chop shut up I'm out Oh God
get away oh no no no okay why why god
dammit why just cuz it's getting closer
to god dammit kidding oh come on No
ah no [ __ ] you back [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay so I
can't beat this game that takes a long
time I cut out quite a bit for it to
make make it a bit more interesting for
you guys but there's a lot of time in
there that it takes to get through that
and with the inconsistency of that match
thing and it's not like I know what
they're trying to go for it's fun
because you can't be panicked when
you're trying to do the lighter I'll
still lose you have to go into it very
calmly but that detract from the
scariness of the game like you can't go
into something like that calmly and
expect people to enjoy a scary game it
had a lot of jump scares and stuff like
that and it was a very scary atmosphere
don't get me wrong game was very scary
but does that mechanic kind of detract
it and also the performance issues I
have an i7 49 60 X extrema different
processor I have a 780ti 32 gigs of ram
and those getting performance issues
like that's that's almost a problem but
criticisms aside it was still a lot of
fun and it still scared me quite a bit
hope you guys enjoyed it if you want to
try to beat it the link is in the
description down there below thank you
developers for making a very scary game
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
Oh